and what to get exponential growth when
I started to focus more on it just
putting in more work one like one
decided I'm gonna do it cuz there's all
these things like oh I wish I could do
this and like you dabble in it and you
know like anything else not just on
YouTube like I kneel in piano I'm gonna
learn photography kneel or whatever like
you dabble here and there and you don't
really get good until you decide like
I'm going to really focus my energy on
this and so one I got clear on what my
brain was all about this one I moved to
believe which is my one word and when I
built my business around so I started
making videos that kind of encompass
that theme so it wasn't all over the
place - I started working with a agency
in New York that trained me on how to be
better on camera you know let's put in
the hustle I was willing to put in the
the time to do it but I didn't have the
skills in terms of being in front of the
camera telling a story well you know
lots that I had to work on and then just
increasing my output so like doing a
video every single day on the channel
then to a day and then three a day
people asked you need to have quality or
quantity to be successful and it's
really both you know like you need to
have quality if you just put up stuff
it's not going to work
you need to have quality but for a lot
of the talent if you're dealing with
business coaches or experts or thought
leaders they need to do the quantity to
get the quality like you need to for me
I had to practice I'd do it again do it
again it was never you know like you're
an expert of what you do and then in the
videography and the editing but you have
to have talent to work with on the other
side of the camera - or you don't have a
good product and that comes from
practicing over and over and over and
over again so I think just making the
decision that this is something that I
want to commit to and I want to focus on
it I want to make it a core part of my
business once you have that mindset then
things start to take off where if
anybody is watching this and thinking
yeah I might do YouTube
it's one of my xxx marketing strategies
then you're probably not committed
enough to really make it something
really valuable you have to understand
that it's something that can really
explode your business forward you have
to be you have to do it not just for the
marketing part of it but you enjoy the
process like I still enjoy making the
videos Wednesday afternoon I sit down
and make videos I love it like I look
forward to Wednesday afternoon right you
want to do this interview I love it
let's do it it's not like oh who does
super interview you know like and only
doing it for the marketing benefit you
have to enjoy the process too and if
you're not the kind of person who wants
to give back who wants to share their
opinions who wants to answer questions
share their thought leadership then it
probably won't be the best fit for you